Network problems and
other failures are something that
we've just got to live with.
What's more,
when we design applications,
we have to take into account
that failures can happen.
And that's important at
all different levels,
at the application level as
well as at the network level.
Here's a story from a system i used
to work on several years before
coming to Udacity.
I'm going to leave off the names and
numbers to protect the not so innocent.
My team system was the back-end
data service that a number of other
services depended on.
It was also really busy.
It got thousands of
requests every second.
And almost all of them
it handled just fine.
But when it got overloaded,
our system would fail some requests
That sometimes the best
thing a system can do.
To shed load and
make sure it can stay up at all.
Unfortunately, one of the services that
used ours responded to failures by
retrying each request up to three times.
So when things started
to get overloaded, and
our system dropped a few requests, that
other server started sending more and
more requests, making the overload
problem very much worse, very quickly.
Fortunately it didn't take us very
long to track down the owners
of other service and politely inform
them that they would be stopping
this little retard behavior now please.
In the next lesson you'll
see a bit about how TCP
handles heavy network load
without falling over.
But don't forget the network can't
save you from buggy applications.
Design your error handling with care.